I don't really know what else you
thought
[Music]
and this is yes I'll call those
chandeliers not Ric Flair sandal Nicola
chandelier
oh I'm secure so I'm from America and I
talk like this
no you know everything I say is kind of
you know but husky like this and you
know he's a jackass I don't like that
guy yeah that could be any American I
was in a very powerful position one of
the most powerful in the country yes
well hello there dear we're going to be
your house gonna come clean thinking
you're her snare oh not maryberry
here no dear Miss Doubtfire
unloaders where those two issues my mom
all right I usually am in movies where I
I can't give you too much proof I'm
always looking for people myself could
be my next job oh my god okay so he was
in black pound four oh it's just black
yeah oh my days I'm really tough but I'm
from the north and I'm a bastard and I'm
a bastard but I'm gonna do something
great sure about war yeah I want to get
it what just no no no one shall we drive
the panic easy easy
so I'm like and I'm Lady B yes I'm gonna
say one line
I like paintings I like I'm gonna even
get out though my name's big storms it's
too easy music yes I'm a cartoon of a
bigger character of a culture and I fix
the toilet and I collect the money like
a cartoon but you can also blame me you
know on that finger oh yeah I'm like
[Music]
what's up I'm Tinie Tempah and I'm
guessing Linga and this the middle one
oh my god
[Music]